nice and complicated two-parter to start
here i was wondering what's something
about what it takes to make a jurassic
movie that hasn't changed since the
original film but then on the other hand
what's something you were able to
accomplish on dominion that 1993 you
would never have imagined was possible
well starting with the similarities um
the gift of genius animatronics starting
with the amazing stan winston you know
to walk on set
and see a creature
either the most
beautiful creature you've ever seen in
your life or the most horrific
disgusting and terrifying creature
that it all comes alive because of
others mastery
and in both films with both sets of
teams
and puppeteers and painters that have
just made
masterful practical dinosaurs it's a
dream come true yet again
um
but
you know
on the first movie
we lived through a level five hurricane
together uh on the island of kauai and
it brought us together in a very deep
way as a family
but nothing
even that could have prepared us
for what it would mean having started
the film
and the pandemic uh occurring
and being the first film back
after we shut down
to witness 400
crew and
cast
assessing a way to support the film
industry to come back to work safely and
to witness
the
teamwork and the sacrifice and the
[Music]
attention to detail and
protectiveness that occurred on this
movie by this crew was unparalleled
and i didn't know
28 years ago that i would move in with
sam neil and jeff goldblum
and bryce and dewanda and chris and
everybody else isabella on this movie bd
and we all lived together for months
and that it would be
amazing and that this movie would be the
greatest team family you could ever feel
because of what we all know we walked
through in these
uncertain and radical times so no one
would have prepared me for that for sure
i feel like i mirrored your experience
because i lived with the pre-existing
franchise all throughout lockdown and
now we get to celebrate a new film i
love it
here we go
all right so i got to bring up the
connection between ellie and alan
because that's been one of the greatest
threads to follow through the franchise
so i'm curious when you first read the
dominion script and saw what they were
finally doing with that connection was
your reaction like it's about time or
did that for any specific reason feel
like now this is the right time for that
to finally be official
well
i love that in the first movie we had a
feminist who is an equal to the men in
an action film and at the beginning of a
franchise
who is
has a deep activist spirit
i only love that in her evolution
she would have the opportunity
to do everything she wants in this life
be completely fearless to use her voice
in the world
and now
tell a man
what she needs him to do to first
help save everyone
and what to sacrifice and that he should
maybe join her for the ride
and then
everything else has an opportunity to
fall into place
but it's not her focus or her priority
and i just feel like it's it's so badass
and so appropriate for dr sattler as
opposed to like i've always been
wondering she's like
i got work to do
something very inspiring about how you
earned that moment here
all right i have so many years worth of
questions for you but i must leave huge
congratulations on dominion can't wait
to see it again thank you so much thanks
for your support
you